shanell is with us in San Antonio
Haitian el how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world military
and my wife is a stay-at-home mom
we just started you sound like you're in
our barrel can you turn can you speak
directly into your phone yes I couldn't
hear me better yes sir thank you so as I
was saying I am active-duty military and
my wife is a stay-at-home mom we started
the baby steps about two months ago
mm-hmm and whenever we have our talk
about the budget she sometimes feels as
if her input shouldn't matter as much
because she's not the one making the
money so my question is how do I help
her so that she can know that I do value
free input for that well the first thing
is you actually have to take her input
she's not gonna think you value it
because you say you do but then never
take it so um you know I my wife was
kind of the same way she would say stuff
like whatever you wanna do honey
which means I'm gonna kill you later if
this goes wrong but you know you know
but you know I would just say no it's
not whatever I want to do I mean we're
gonna sit down here we're gonna look at
this together and I need your input and
I want you to look at this and just draw
her in ask questions about stuff that's
on the budget is this enough for the is
this enough for the budget for the food
for the grocery store or we got the kids
right and we got the clothing budget
right here and and and then when there
is a big decision
of any kind a big purchase a car that
breaks down or something like that when
there's something that comes along
that's got a little bit of oomph to it
and it's sighs make sure you sit down
and go over that weather and you know I
you know I you may do this for a lot of
years before she really quote-unquote
feels equal quote-unquote in terms of
her
vote on budget issues does she have
equal input with you you know if you
asked Sharon today she might tell you
that she still doesn't feel completely
equal I've you her as that but but I'm
the money guy and so I'm you know got a
lot of strong opinions about this stuff
I got it ideas about where we're gonna
go and you know I'm pretty forceful in
my in my selling of an idea and so
sometimes she's like well no matter what
I think
oh yeah it does matter you know you got
to get over yourself there little martyr
and sit down here and do this you know
and we got to work together on this
stuff and so the truth is in that an
actual practical fact tactically her
input is right there but not necessarily
that she always feel that way even then
and you know you're not responsible for
that you can't fix that that's her
decision as to whether she feels that or
not if you're tactically doing it but be
very careful with the words you use and
how strong you push back on something
especially go ahead and lose a few
battles of if she gives some input that
you don't necessarily agree with go
ahead and go with it anyway unless it's
damaging if it's a small thing shut up
and do it and then that drawers are in
because you are counting her vote at
that point you are valuing her vote at
that point and she naturally is going to
feel more valued but we do not do
tactically under any circumstances major
financial decisions major giving major
purchases without talking to each other
I mean we just do not do it and that is
a tactical practical fat now if you ask
her how she feels about that I I'm not
responsible for that I can't make you
feel something but the truth is is that
at the Ramsey House we do not do those
things and so you know I'm at least
getting the advantage of her input
whether or not she like is all jacked up
about it or not that kind of thing